welcome to another you know I was in
Portland and I really really this is the
first time I ever felt this is I could
live there you say that all the time
about where that's five years about
where Portland and Hawaii and Hawaii
right Hawaii
but why can i express myself several
times no because you just said this is
the first time I did I also lie a lot
you know man oh can I tell you something
this happened today I never I didn't
tell anybody at this uh so I tried
something today and him probably didn't
work so I get a call Keegan
Keyes has a new show mm-hmm I go who and
they go Keys I could yeah yeah yeah so I
love them right huge key and Peele fan
so I go and what is it so it's basically
a it's like an amazing race kind of a
show mm-hm and you know it's it's
celebrity with a comedian and they go
out and they do physical challenges
mm-hmm and Cassatt solve puzzles and
whatnot yeah so I was in there I think I
had them on my side so I go you know
what I'm gonna do something that you
guys never seen before and there's three
executives in a room is this just a
general meeting no they walk they wanted
to see if I'm they want me if you're the
guy if I'm one of the guys okay that's
cool they go what are you standing I
have a monologue I just am improvising I
think oh but please sit I'm standing so
you sit and I'm gonna tell you something
right now too
after I'm done with my monologue and
this has never happened before I'm just
gonna leave the room without saying
goodbye
and you go what I go yeah I have a
monologue I improvise it listen please
let me commit to this because now if I
don't do it it's gonna be even weirder
you're gonna look weak I'm gonna look
weird weak so I stood up and you can
tell that they're like you know how they
adjust they don't know what they think I
might might shoot up the place yeah I'm
not gonna to because I'm I had to go
through the gates and I have the proper
ID and I'm gonna you know I've never
done anything like that but um yeah
before you know that everyone in this
room confirm that I'm a Christian I
don't believe in those kind of thing
confirm that so arm so I did this
monologue I go I know
I'm perfect for the show I have old
history with and then I go James Corden
yes because I go oh yeah the only
problem is I said the only problem is is
that I have a friend who's Irish his
name is Mark
I actually said this in the room uh-huh
they go what I go yeah my friend Mark
invited me to two FIFA tournaments with
James Corden they go yeah and I go yeah
I go the first time I said I would show
up I never showed up and apparently it
[ __ ] the tournament up and the second
time they hesitantly asked and I said no
they really needed me so I think James
Corden is mad at me because I didn't
show up to two FIFA tournaments but if
he's okay with it and Keegan still wants
me and you guys like me I'd love to be
involved and I just left
what if they would have offered you
something
I just left I know I just loved and I'm
giggling to myself in the hallway and
then a couple of hours later um my agent
called me and he goes why'd you do that
your response I go what I didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking about you
just left okay yeah he does all right
what'd they say they got nothing they
just say you left I feel like it was a
power movie but dude how funny you could
have been did you hear them laugh a
little bit you're good that's a thing
you got when I said goodbye and I closed
the door of course does itah listen it
got a big laugh yeah and then one said
some one person said to other and the
god the guy was like that was exciting
for this yeah and I just left so maybe
right